people are scared on the internet i
don't know why people are scared they
see bitcoin we're at 69 000 the other
day all-time high we're down just below
60 000 right now we've declined about 15
from the all-time high in the last few
days volatility it's it happens it's his
friend with bitcoin it goes up it goes
down it's been going up a lot more than
it goes down though so when you look at
it compared to other assets the s p is
right around 4 700 again close to an
all-time high they print money that's
what happens gold 1800 gold down 3.8
percent not very volatile there up or
down silver 24 euro yen etc but when we
look at bitcoin from a fundamental
perspective the market cap is sitting
right around
1.12 trillion the inflation rate is 1.78
again 90
of the bitcoin supply is already in
circulation has already been issued it's
almost 19 million of the 21 million
bitcoin settlement volume is uh almost
28 billion over the last 24 hours
all-time high and active addresses we're
close to a million gbtc premium
continues to trade at a discount and uh
the microstrategy premium is 17 so we're
about 14 to 15 down from the all-time
high people are freaking out what are
you thinking john i'm not freaking out
you're not freaking looking for a buying
opportunity are you buying more i'm
trying to so do you buy bitcoin uh on
the daily you're basically just dollar
cost averaging it or are you looking and
adding more when you see dips like this
i'm dollar cost averaging it but i
obviously have a long term vision for
the asset of a five ten year lifetime
kind of vision so i'm buying when i see
buying opportunities uh we're in a bull
market right now so we expect it kind of
to go
back into maybe a bear market next year
when the having cycle and all the kind
of rush ends but i'm looking for any
opportunity to buy to be honest and i
think this is a great price not
financial advice but i think it's a
great price to buy bitcoin i think it
will only appreciate well i think a lot
of people too they're looking at plan
b's models right and he has a few
different models but the one that
they're uh i guess somewhat concerned
about is his his stock to flow floor
model which he previously stated he his
lowest base case scenario was 98 000
that bitcoin would hit in november uh
there's less than i maybe even less now
than a one percent chance that that's
gonna happen uh based on kind of the
financial markets and the models that
they're predicting so i don't think
that's necessarily a cause for concern
we've seen a lot of volatility in the
price he's still extremely confident in
his normal stock to flow model which
says over this halving cycle we will
average one hundred thousand price for
bitcoin we've been under a hundred
thousand drastically under a hundred
thousand for the entire having cycle so
far so i'm not a mathematician but that
means we're gonna have to go drastically
over a hundred thousand to average out
for a hundred but ten years ago what
were the odds that bitcoin's sitting at
sixty thousand dollars a coin today oh i
think people people uh get concerned i
saw articles earlier that bitcoin dipped
five percent bitcoin dipped six percent
in a day look a year ago we were sitting
at ten thirteen fifteen thousand dollars
for a bitcoin right we're we're
drastically outperforming i think what
most people on wall street expected uh
and everything is going swimmingly from
a price return standpoint we got the
chart right here look
232 percent bitcoin has appreciated in
the last year as we're seeing inflation
at record high levels the wealth
inequality gap in this country has
widened to record levels and gold which
is supposed to store as an inflation
hedge asset has underperformed it is
literally down on the year so bitcoin
has clearly shown that it is that
inflation heads asset of this uh of this
generation it has taken that in my
opinion guys like mark cuban and others
who do not necessarily believe in the
future of bitcoin from a transactional
perspective have said it is the best
store of value in the world it's digital
uh it's transferable it's it's based on
mathematics it's software et cetera you
can name a million different reasons why
but it has proven the data has shown the
end result is bitcoin is a better store
of value just look at the numbers gold
is literally down over the last year
john what do you think about when you
look at that two
two over two million percent return in
the last 10 years hindsight is obviously
2020 but this has been one of the
greatest investments i've ever seen in
my lifetime for sure and i think
anyone's ever seen over a 10-year period
over a one-year period i mean gold's
down as the inflation had asset and as
they print money obviously you're going
to see the value of the dollar go down
but you're also going to see the s p and
assets like that go up so it's important
to be invested yeah and if you look at
the s p right speaking of that it's up
31 over the over the last year 51 over
two years and 77 82 etc those numbers
are great those numbers are fantastic in
a normal year i think when most people
do i remember when i first graduated
college most of the models that
everything predicts off of savings
income earnings uh investing and 401ks
et cetera is based on if you can earn
eight percent a year literally eight
percent a year is what most of that is
based on anything better than that is
really good anything below that is kind
of underperforming certain benchmarks so
that obviously adjusts depending on
where you're at in your career how
you're investing your risk strategy etc
but when you think about eight percent
bitcoin and other digital assets have
way way way outperformed that the s p
has also but to a much lesser degree so
i think people are looking at these
numbers and some people say hey look
maybe it's time to back up a little bit
maybe it's a little too uh risky maybe
we're going to see a downturn et cetera
but when i think it comes to bitcoin
when you just look at the mathematics
from a supply and demand standpoint
19 million of the 21 million literally
90 of the supply has been issued already
it's already in circulation
a large percent of that has
been lost forever or has been off
exchanges for five ten ten years etc and
then there's a portion of that uh a
large portion of that eighty to
eighty-five percent that literally
hasn't been moved in 90 days 90 days so
like that's bitcoin that's off exchanges
that's bitcoin that's not moving that's
bitcoin that is being held by long-term
holders and we talk about this all the
time but when you only have to worry
about one side of the equation supply
and demand wise it makes it much easier
to look at your investments and say hey
this is something that i believe in as
long as adoption continues to occur
right we've all seen the charts when you
look at adoption compared to the
internet it's it's a beautiful chart
it's a beautiful beautiful chart and
that's going to continue right news
every single day literally every single
day and it's easy to sit here on a
day-by-day basis and forget about things
that have already happened but countries
are adopting it uh billionaires are all
buying it corporations are putting on
their bounty like there's just day after
day there's things being added up and it
all adds to that demand side and when
supply is fixed and it's constrained we
know exactly how much it is from a
programmatic software standpoint it
makes it much easier to invest in this
stuff and i think what we've seen is
we've seen a whole generation start to
do that and you can tell by these
numbers right here this is a perfect
chart right
everyone is nervous that we've dropped
15 from the all-time high and asking if
we're going into a bear market or
whatever it might be bitcoin has only
been above the current level for 47 days
about one percent of its entire life it
has spent above this price so we're
still at or near all-time highs right
from a price standpoint and especially
when you zoom out and you look at the
totality of the the life of bitcoin and
i don't think it would be surprising
anyone if you came back in two three
four weeks and we're materially higher
than here right this is a zone that
typically people have been buying and i
think we have another chart uh we'll get
to it in a second that's going to show
what some guys are doing buying or some
some people are doing buying but the
next one is always people always talk
about volatility right and they're
scared about bitcoin because of
volatility but the sharp ratio this is
this is wall street's best friend this
is their metric they made this up they
said hey look we're going to measure
things on a volatility adjusted basis
right so bonds are less volatile stocks
are more volatile so you should expect a
higher equity return dealing for some of
that volatility bitcoin on a sharp ratio
basis has outperformed everything
drastically drastically right we talk
about the s p 500 it's up a massive
amount bitcoin is obviously up a massive
amount it's much more volatile but on a
risk-adjusted basis using the sharpe
ratio their metric hey it's their metric
bitcoin is outperforming the equity
markets is outperforming gold is
outperforming bonds is outperforming
real estate it's been the best
performing asset for a decade now and
there are still some people that are
doubting it what portion of volatility
do you take into mind when you're
looking at bitcoin it's very volatile
and volatility works both ways right it
goes up goes down you just have to be
long-term that is the main thing i think
with bitcoin is as a sore value asset
you can't you can day trade this stuff
and you can make money day trading you
can lose my day trading um but being
long term i think is the safest bet
because you don't have to view it every
single day we were talking about all
those all coins that came up and it's
like look if you got to check your
investment by the second by the minute
by the hour then that's not really
something i want to be involved in i
don't need that stress in my life of
just checking investments every single
day um i check the bitcoin price every
day and to be honest i don't know why
because even if it's up i'm not gonna
sell any if it goes down maybe it's a
buying opportunity but i'm not gonna
sell any when it goes down i think
people change on that too when i first
started buying bitcoin i was checking
the price ferociously ferociously like
every day like every minute and when you
start first investing i actually don't
think that's a bad thing right you're
checking it all the time and it's not
just bitcoin it's any asset if you put a
material portion of your work of your
net worth or any uh kind of material
amount of money into something you're
gonna be checking all the time it's
human nature so i don't necessarily
think that's a problem but i think it
goes away over time and i think with
bitcoin it actually gets better because
there's things that you can't control
outside of your force you don't have to
worry about monetary policy you don't
have to worry about company earnings you
don't have to worry about any of this
stuff that goes on in other markets
right so when you think about sure
there's news that goes on day to day but
if you just zoom out and you look from
the long term
horizon what is this technology why do i
believe in it and is there going to be
global adoption to a level where this is
going to materially increase in price
given the fix and constraints apply and
i think in my opinion at least that's an
easy question and that that's a question
that i've answered years ago which is
like okay that's why you go in and you
buy a bunch of bitcoin and then if you
start thinking about a savings account
it makes it easier and easier right and
you start stop looking at it every day
from a price standpoint and maybe you
check it once a day maybe you check it
once every two days maybe check it twice
a day but it doesn't really matter
because when you zoom out a lot of those
feelings go underneath your go go under
the surface right and it just doesn't
really matter so i think what we'll see
is the more people get used to bitcoin
and the volatility and the price
continues to appreciate year over year
and a lot of it is just evidence-based
right the easiest thing is hey look at
past returns and we say hey over the
last year it's outperformed everything
over the last two years over the last
five years or the last 10 years and you
start to get that evidence it makes it
much easier but this is another great
chart because this shows performance
versus all the other all the other
assets that people argue against right
so bitcoin everyone calls it digital
gold or some people call digital gold
there it is compared to gold the s p
nasdaq and treasuries etc so it's
outperforming basically everything on
every kind of basis that you can think
of right roi compounded annual growth
the volatility has been a little bit
higher but when you adjust that on the
sharpe ratio for five years it's been
much better from a price appreciation
standpoint and that evens out so look
everyone always says volatility like
it's some like nasty words like it's
some bad word but if volatility's going
up it's a good thing and that's what
bitcoin has done historically sure
there's some bumps in the road but like
i said when you zoom out it looks much
much better when everything's going up
into the right and financial advice
aside right like that's not just go buy
things that have gone up a lot because
that's never good advice but again when
you start thinking about adoption rates
and looking at countries that are doing
this and corporation that are buying it
and the aspect of digital gold and as a
store of value when we have 6.2 cpi in
this country and some people think it's
much higher the case for buying an asset
like this
especially combined with the idea that
it's historically outperformed
everything and the fundamentals makes it
much easier